hi friends if you watch our show then
you know the daily Deni was dark
yesterday admittedly was because I was
sick but today I don't feel any better
like most of you I woke up shot dismayed
and at a loss for words after what
happened in Las Vegas and even today
it's still a lot to take in and I'm not
here to try and make sense of it because
you just can't it doesn't make any sense
knowing this tragedy happened at a music
festival a place for me my friends and
so many people I know out there seek
refuge it's heartbreaking for me
concerts and music festivals is like
this perfect bubble and to think that
innocent lives were lost in their
perfect bubble I'm just sad and I'm not
gonna stand up here on a soapbox but let
me say this
there's a lot of awfulness in the world
right now but I have to believe there is
more good than there is bad I have to
and I hope you don't give up on that
idea either be the good go hug the heck
out of your friends and family be kind
to one another and most importantly be
kind of yourself today I'm gonna try and
bring in a little light and out of this
pain you know out of this pain out of
the grief out of the sadness there's
also been some inspiring moments and
tributes from celebrities that I want to
share in the wake of the tragedy Jason
Aldean who's on the stage when the
gunman opened fire at the route 91
festival shared a short message to his
fans and later on Monday
Jason posted a lengthy message
encouraging unity at this difficult time
writing quote at the end of the day we
aren't Democrats or Republicans whites
or blacks men or women we are all humans
and we were all Americans and it's time
to start acting like it and stand
together as one Katy Perry also helps
spread the love during her tour stop at
Madison Square Garden in New York City
on Monday she had the crowd shouting I
love you to each other and had this
inspiring message to share
[Applause]
[Music]
each other
[Applause]
meanwhile Miley Cyrus gave two poignant
performances on The Tonight Show last
night she and Adam Sandler opened the
show with a cover of Dido's no freedom
dedicating the moment to the victims and
their families
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
there's no without prettier
[Music]
Friedel no freedom
obviously Vegas is weighing heavily on
everybody right now but also on the
hearts of millions is Tom petty petty
passed away yesterday after suffering
cardiac arrest
it was just 66 years old it's hard to
believe we've lost another great music
legend and Tom and his band the
Heartbreakers just ended their 40th
anniversary tour here at the Hollywood
Bowl telling the crowd it would be his
final tour one concert goer told ET he
seemed upbeat and energetic healthy and
happy of course the celeb tributes have
been pouring all over social media from
makjang Iran Mayor Alice Cooper and last
night Coldplay honored Petty's memory
during their Portland Oregon show with
the cover of his hit free fallin
alongside musician Pete buck
[Music]
as you can imagine et has spent a lot of
time with the rock legend over the years
so of course we dug into the et vault
and found this 1990 interview wit Tom
here he is in his own words I won't tell
you why I won't quit because I won't
leave because there's no reason for me
to leave I can still do this I feel very
fortunate just to be alive and healthy
as corny as that may sound
I feel very unfortunate ya know this has
a gun in my head rest in peace mr. petty
and finally today is October 3rd and you
know what that means on October 3rd he
asked me what day it was
it's October 3rd that's right it's the
day the Internet has christen Mean Girls
day now in honor of today Tina Fey
herself handed out cheese fries to a
long line of people buying tickets to
the upcoming Broadway musical she must
have gotten the memo that I am on an all
carb diet but more importantly the cast
teamed up and harnessed fans interest in
the movie today to give back to victims
and families of the Vegas shooting Lacey
Chabert Amanda Seyfried Jonathan Bennett
and Daniel France se filmed a video for
their GoFundMe campaign their goal to
raise $300,000 for the national
compassion fund a program in the
national center for victims of crime he
has learned it was Aaron Samuels himself
Jonathan Bennett who thought of the idea
and texted his cast mates Jonathan told
et exclusively what happened in Vegas
hit too close to home and he realized he
needed to do something before them got
on board for this but as for whether
they would ever do a mean-girl sequel
Jonathan says he would totally do it and
it's just honored to be part of the
whole situation
either way it's amazing to see them use
this little pop culture phenomenon for
some good you guys come on how you can
get involved we have this post up now on
ET online calm all right guys that's it
for today and I honestly do not like
having to talk about such heavy things
but it was obviously hard to ignore so
thank you for watching I got to say I
love this community we're building
through this show and I'm sending you
guys the biggest hug right now we'll see
you tomorrow where I promise we'll try
and have some fun all right love to you
all